[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: OK, so
what happened last time?
So we talked about
the workhorse model
of classical or
classical economics,
in terms of discounting-- the
exponential discounted utility
model.
This is a very useful
model for many settings.
It's been very useful for
explain and understand
a bunch of behaviors.
However, this model
has a few assumptions
that create some predictions
that are not necessarily
borne out in the data.
And we're trying to improve
on those assumptions
and make the model
more realistic.
What are these assumptions
and what kinds of examples
did I show you that
perhaps were not
consistent with the
exponential discounting model?
I'll actually show them to you.
But can somebody explain
to you what they are
and why those are not
consistent with the exponential
discounting model?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You
shouldn't determine--
you shouldn't care about
whether it's a [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So one key assumption in the
exponential discounting model
is that there's one
parameter, delta,
that essentially steers
how much you care about
different periods of time,
the present and the future,
or two future periods.
The key assumption here
is that how much weight
do you put on
different time periods,
on early and a later date,
is constant across time.
So from today versus
tomorrow, there's
the same difference compared to,
like, when you look at a year
from now and a year
and a day from now,
or 20 days and 21 days.
The difference, if you care
more about the present,
that's constant across time
from today's perspective,
also from future perspective.
That's one assumption.
And what evidence
did we see or show
that that's not consistent with?
AUDIENCE: Choosing a reward.
Do you want the money now
or is this today or in
a year or [INAUDIBLE]?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So we saw some
evidence that people
are impatient in the short run.
So when it comes to today
versus tomorrow or today
versus in a week
from now, people
tend to be fairly impatient.
They tend to discount
the future a lot.
Now, there's sort of
two issues with that.
One is, if you do the same
thing about asking people
about future rewards, people
tend to be more patient.
So the discount factors
that you elicit,
we'll talk a little bit about
that in a recitation, as well.
The discount factors
are just different
for the same intervals of time.
Second, if you take the short
run and patience seriously--
if you sort of say,
OK, I take your choices
from today versus tomorrow or
from today versus next week
and [INAUDIBLE] run
that forward, you
got sort of absurd
implications as in, like,
if you really seriously discount
a week from now by a lot,
then you shouldn't care
about a year from now,
five years from now.
You shouldn't care
about that at all.
However, we see
in the real world,
people have lots of-- people
care about the future a lot.
People save money.
People get education
and so on and so forth.
So it can't be in
some ways that they're
really impatient in
the long run, as well.
So that's, like, number one.
What about point number two?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Your decision
now for the future
should be the same
as [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
That's called dynamic
or time consistency.
That's an assumption or
implication of the exponential
discounting model.
That is to say, if
I make some choices
for the future, for future
periods, about how I--
what I'm going to study next
week or in a year from now,
or whether I'm going to
exercise and so on, for choices
that involve time in the
future, once that time comes,
absent new information or
absent circumstances change,
I should follow
through with my plans.
And so if that's not the
case, then what we say
is that preferences are
dynamically inconsistent.
That is to say, I have all
sorts of plans of exercising
next week and so on.
The next week comes.
Surprise, I'm not
following through.
That essentially means my
preferences are inconsistent.
And that's sort of evidence
against the exponential
discounting model.
OK.
Number three, demand
for commitment.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
There are [INAUDIBLE] people
will often do that [INAUDIBLE]
and that shows that
people [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So one sort of key
assumption or one sort
of key insight from sort
of economics in general,
or classical economics, and it's
like, more choices are good.
Like, if you have more
options available,
that's great for you, because
you can take advantage of them.
You never know
whether there's going
to be uncertainty or certain
circumstances change.
So you should never
restrict your choices
because you never know.
Maybe in the future, maybe
circumstances change.
Maybe I got really
busy, or whatever.
Things happen.
So more choice tends to be good.
So in the neoclassical or
classical economics model,
there's no scope
for or no reason
to restrict your choices because
more choices in the future
are always good.
However, if you're worried about
your future self misbehaving
in certain ways,
if you're worried
about your future
self not exercising,
eating too many potato chips,
and so on and so forth,
you might want to engage
in commitment devices,
either by taking
away certain options,
like restricting your choice
set to a smaller choice set,
or, less drastically, making
future choices more expensive.
That is to say,
for example, if I
say I'm going to
submit or write a paper
by the end of this week,
if I'm going to tell you
if I don't do that I'm
going to give you $100,
well, what I'm going
to do essentially
is I'm making not writing
the paper more expensive.
And the neoclassical
or the classical model
had the exponential
discounting model
has essentially
no scope for that.
Why would I ever do that?
Because who knows.
Maybe I'll get sick
or stuff happens.
So there's no reason to do that.
There's no benefit
of doing that.
And it's a potential cost.
So if I see myself or somebody
else restricting their choices,
that's a violation of the
exponential discounting model.
And the reason, of course,
for that is number two.
We know there's
preference for it.
If you think there are
future preference reversals,
if I think that in the
future I might change
my preferences in a
way that I don't like,
if I want my future self
to behave in certain ways
that I prefer right now, I might
want to restrict my choice set.
I might certain unpreferrable--
like, less preferable
options more costly.
OK.
Good.
So then what we did next
is to say, OK, now--
so I showed you a bunch
of evidence of that.
And then what we did is
then we sort of presented
a slight deviation from
the exponential discounting
model, which is the
quasi-hyperbolic discounting
model.
That model is, in
some sense, very
similar to the exponential
discounting model
that I showed you, except
for some small difference.
There's an additional
parameter that's called beta.
What does this beta do?
It's like a short term discount
factor that essentially guides
all discounting or
determines all discounting
between the present
period, right now,
versus anything
that's in the future.
One broad question is like,
what are the time periods?
Is it daily?
Is it yearly?
Is it monthly or whatever?
There's actually quite a
bit of research on this
that people try to
figure this out.
Usually we think the beta or
the time horizon of the beta
is actually just a few
days, even just a few hours.
So for our purposes, we can
say it's daily or today.
And anything that you'll
see in the problem
sets and so on, it needs
to be always defined.
But think of beta
essentially anything
that's like today or in
the next couple of days.
Anything outside of that
scope is essentially outside
of the scope of beta and
sort of in the future.
Now, what does this beta do?
Well, it helps us to
separate discounting
for short horizons
and long horizons,
because if you think about
discounting between the present
and anything in the future,
the data can steer that, right?
If beta is 0.7, 0.6,
or 0.8 or whatever,
I can now be impatient
for the present.
I can now prefer, say, $10
today versus $12 in the future.
The beta will make
sure that that happens.
But when you look at
all future periods,
the beta is in all
future periods.
It appears everywhere
in the utility function
in all future periods.
So the beta does not
affect how am I discounting
any future time periods.
So then the delta
is steering that.
We usually think that
delta is close to 1.
It's something like yearly
0.95 or 0.99 or the like.
So delta is essentially
reasonably close to 1,
such that I can
be fairly patient
between 10 years from now and
11 years from now and 15 years
from now.
It doesn't matter much to me.
There's only going to be
some slight discounting.
I prefer probably things
that are happening five years
from now from things
that are happening
30 years from now for the
same sort of stuff happening.
But people tend to
be fairly patient.
Do you have any
questions about that?
OK.
So let me now sort of spend, in
fact, the rest of the lecture
just talking about
details of this model,
in part sort of
building intuition,
sort of showing you the
mechanics of how that works
and how, essentially, having
an additional discount
parameter of the data
affects people's choices.
And second, we're going to
talk about something that's
quite important, which is the
question of sophistication
versus naivete.
What do I mean by that?
Well, in the exponential
discounting model,
by assumption, the preferences
are time consistent.
What does that mean?
If I make plans
for the future, I
will follow through
with those plans.
So in some sense,
it doesn't really
matter what I think I'm
going to do in the future,
because essentially,
I'm going to do anyway
what I'm going to plan anyway.
So the only thing
I need to know is
right now what I'm going to do.
And then if I make that plan,
unless circumstances change,
I'm going to just
follow through.
That's not true here anymore,
as I'm going to show you.
So now it's the case that if
I make some plans right now,
these plans might change
in the future because
of my preferences.
Even in the absence
of new information
or new circumstances, once
tomorrow comes or next week
comes, I might sort of
prefer different things.
So now the preference are not
dynamically consistent anymore.
So what I prefer today might
not be what I prefer next week.
So that now leads
to a complication.
Now I need to
understand, well, what
are my beliefs about what I'm
going to do in the future is
quite important.
Do I have correct beliefs?
Do I understand that
I'm present biased?
Do I understand
that in the future
I might be impatient, as well?
Or am I naive?
Do I think right now I'm present
biased, but tomorrow comes
or next week I'm going to
exercise, do the problem set
early, and so on and so forth?
And as we're going to see, that
will lead to quite different--
starkly different
conclusions or implications
that are quite important for
outcomes, welfare, and so on.
OK.
So let me give you
some examples first.
So first, if you have a
discount function for beta
equals 1/2 and
delta close to 1--
for our purposes,
often I'm going
to set delta to 1, not
because I necessarily
think that delta is 1.
Delta is probably 0.99,
0.95, or the like.
I'm just setting it to
1 to make the algebra
or sort of any
problem set exercises
and so on being less messy.
Speaking of which,
problem set exercises--
Pierre-Luc who sits in
the very back and checks
whether you are using
your laptop only
for classwork, Pierre-Luc
sort of mostly in charge
of doing the problem sets.
So he also has office
hours, to which
you can come and ask specific
questions about the problem
sets.
Of course, he's also very
happy to answer questions
about Piazza or
in any other way.
When are your office hours?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: 1:30 on Friday.
And where are they?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Perfect.
So it's on the course website.
So if you have
specific questions
about the problem set,
again, in the recitation,
we'll discuss quite a few
issues related to that.
But then if you have specific
questions about the problem
set, Pierre-Luc will be the
best equipped to answer those.
OK.
So if you have quasi-hyperbolic
discounting preferences,
with beta equals 1/2
and delta equals 1,
your discounting function
looks, essentially, as follows.
The first period is
sort of normalized to 1.
[INAUDIBLE] like one
about the current period.
In the future then it's, like,
beta delta, beta delta square,
beta delta to the
power of 3, and so on.
But if you sort of now
use delta equals 1,
you get, essentially-- you
care about the present 1.
And everything in the
future is discounted by 1/2.
OK, so relative to
the present period,
all future periods
are worth less.
So I care a lot
about the present.
That's why we call it sort of
present bias or present focus.
I care a lot more about
the present than anything
in the future.
Now, second, all discounting
in this specific example
takes place between the present
and the immediate future.
So I only care about--
in terms of discounting--
all future periods
are the same for me.
I don't care about
whether things
are in five periods or six
or seven periods from now.
That's all the same for me,
because delta, in this case,
is 1.
Instead, what I care
about is that today
versus tomorrow or today versus
three days from now, and so on.
Again, usually delta
would not be one.
So if you had a delta that's,
like, 0.99 or the like,
there would be some discounting
in the future, as well.
But not in this case.
So that's sort of capturing the
intuition that the long run--
in the long run, we
are relatively patient.
There is essentially no
discounting happening anymore.
And so the utils a
year from now are just
as valuable as utils
in two years from now.
So then that also means that
the timing of decisions or--
the decisions are
sensitive to the timing
of costs and benefits, when
exactly did they occur.
It matters a lot
whether stuff happens
today versus tomorrow or today
versus three days from now.
It matters much less about
whether stuff happens in three
days versus four days from now.
I'm going to show you
some examples of that.
But just to sort of
give you some sense of,
like, why is this called
quasi-hyperbolic or hyperbolic
discounting?
So have your three functions.
I'm not sure how well
you can see this.
But there's, like,
a sort of pink line
that's essentially like
an exponential curve.
That's essentially what
exponential discounting looks
like.
Essentially what you see is
sort of a constant, if you want,
sort of decline of like
the discount function.
And then I've also
plotted to you
hyperbolic discounting,
which is essentially
like a true hyperbolic curve.
That's essentially
the thing that you
see on the left, the one
that's sort of like much
steeper at the beginning.
And then there is
quasi-hyperbolic discounting
that's essentially
quite similar in shape,
as you can see, to the
hyperbolic discounting,
except for the fact that
it's not continuous.
There's a jump from going one
to beta at the very beginning.
It's not a continuous function.
Essentially, there's
a discrete jump
between today and the future.
And then essentially it
behaves very similarly
to the exponential
discounting curve.
But that's just to tell
you it doesn't really--
you don't have to worry about
the hyperbolic discounting
and so on.
We're not going to
discuss that very much.
But that's just for
you to understand
why is that the name?
Well, it's because essentially
it's quasi-hyperbolic.
It's not really hyperbolic
because it's not
really hyperbola.
But in fact, it looks
quite similar, effectively.
So then when you think about
goods that you might consume,
there's different
types of goods.
There's leisure goods and
there's investment goods.
Let's sort of start
with leisure goods.
What's a leisure good?
A leisure good is a good
that has immediate rewards
and delayed costs.
One example would
be eating candy.
So eating candy, of course, you
get immediate utility benefits.
It's pleasurable to eat candy.
So that's positive.
In this case, suppose the
benefits are the pleasure
of eating candy right now.
But often eating candy, it
leads to delayed health costs
or delayed costs at
the dentist's office,
which summarizes C health
of 3 in the future.
If you now say, well,
if beta equals 1/2
and a delta equals 1, well,
you can sort think about,
would you eat candy today
or candy in the future?
So first starting off
with eating candy today--
well, if you sort of calculate
the costs and benefits
of eating candy, the pleasure
that you get from candy is 2.
If you discount
the future by beta,
essentially everything in the
future is discounted by beta,
it's like 1/2 times 3.
So if you sort of
do that calculation,
you get something positive.
So if you think about
eating candy right now,
the answer is yes, because 2
minus 1/2 times 3 is positive
and you're going to do that.
If instead you think
about, should I
eat candy in the future?
Well, you get
different implications.
The answer is no.
Why is the answer no?
Because if you're in
the future, everything
is discounted that's
happening in the future, both
the pleasure that comes
from eating candy next week,
but also the delayed costs are
essentially discounted by beta.
So then you essentially
just have, like, 1/2.
This is the beta for everything
in the future times two,
which are the benefits,
minus 3, which are the costs.
And that's smaller than 0.
So you're not going to do that.
And that's sort of a
general feature for leisure
good, as we call them.
These have immediate rewards
and delayed benefits.
And so what you
tend to do is you
tend to overconsume them
in the present relative
to long run plans.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are you only
considering [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
So yeah, you can think of
this as, like, a shorthand
form of saying, for example,
suppose you eat a lot of candy
or, like, on one day you
eat candy and suppose
you know-- these are
repeated choices,
but I'm sort of
aggregating it into one.
You'll have, essentially,
health costs in the future.
Suppose you get dental
pain in the future.
Each period you have dental pain
starting at age 30 or 40 or 50.
Now, you can sort of think
of this as like each day
you're going to have
negative utility.
What I'm doing now is I'm
sort of collapsing that
into one day in a sense of
just making sure that-- to make
it sort of tractable.
So you can think of
the delayed health
costs as a summary of
the health costs overall.
Instead you could also
write down 0.1 for your 40,
0.1 for your 41, and
so on and so forth,
and sort of aggregating
in that way.
But that's just for
simplicity here.
Similarly, you could
also say each day
you'll have essentially
a choice to eat candy.
And these things sort of add up.
And again, sort of simplifying
in a sense of saying,
like, should I
eat candy overall,
which is a number
of different choices
that each are between the
present and the future.
That's just like changing the
units in some way overall.
I think the structure of
the problem is the same.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So
obviously this is kind
of comparing apples and oranges.
But I the one kind of
[INAUDIBLE] is your health is
kind of the sum of a bunch
of actions that you did over
your lifetime that
affect your health,
versus candy is something that--
the pleasure that you get
out of candy is exactly--
fully [INAUDIBLE].
So when people-- when you
do this kind of [INAUDIBLE]
discounting and you're trying
to compare health in the future,
like, pleasure now, the fact
that the candy contributes such
a small amount to
your overall health,
it seems kind of like
an apples to oranges--
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
To some degree, I
think that's right.
I think it's, in some sense,
that's just an example.
So I could show you
many different things
that are sort of
similar in structure.
I'm using candy just
to make it concrete.
You could do the same with
problem sets and other pain,
or exercising, and
so on and so forth.
I think at the end of the day,
I think that's exactly right.
For a lot of choices
that people make--
be it brushing their
teeth, be it exercising,
be it eating
healthily and so on,
often the costs or
the benefits are
very salient in the present.
They're very salient
and concrete.
Right now you have a
cookie in front of you.
You can eat it.
You'll be happy,
and that's for sure.
Sometime in 20
years from now, you
might be sort of like unhealthy.
You might get dental problems
and so on and so forth.
Not only is it sort
of very far away,
but it's also very diffuse.
It's also maybe unlikely.
Like, there's a chance
of getting a heart
attack at age 70.
Maybe, maybe not.
Maybe you'll be just fine.
So it's more complicated in
a lot of health decisions.
So there's other research
saying, like, well, partially
it's about uncertainty.
Partially it's about
the future being diffuse
and very sort of unclear.
One part of that people tend
to think is time preferences.
But I think what you're
saying is the world is
more complicated than that.
And that's for sure true.
What I'm sort of saying is,
like, thinking about time
preferences can help you
understand some choices
that people make over time.
Having said that, there's
lots of other aspects
here, which we're sort
of grossly simplifying.
But I think the key part here--
I think what's really important
for a lot of health choices
tends to be that people--
that exactly as you
say, there's a lot
of-- like, thousands
of really small choices
that sort of add up to
something like-- what we call it
unhealthy behavior in some way.
And each of them are concrete
in some sense in terms
of the costs and benefits.
Like, brushing your teeth
is like costly in some sense
for five minutes or whatever.
Eating candy is happy
for a few minutes,
as well, very concretely.
And then the costs are
often diffuse in the future
and so on.
That's really important.
We're going to talk a
little bit about this.
But we sort of--
for now at least
abstracting,
essentially, that away.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Why is it better
than the [INAUDIBLE]..
Why is it [INAUDIBLE] and
what actually [INAUDIBLE]
better than the
exponential model?
FRANK SCHILBACH: So
the exponential model
would not predict you
this type of behavior.
So if you think about now
we get to this-- like,
if you sort of say you want to
make choices for the future,
the exponential
discounter would give you
the same choices for
the future versus what
actually-- when
the future arrives.
So I'm going to show you a
sort of-- more in the context
of problem set, I'm going to
show you this behavior that
the exponential model cannot--
just not explain.
Like, the exponential discounter
would say, either I like candy
and I don't care about--
or I just don't worry that much
about the health costs and I
eat candy, or I don't.
I'm really worried
about the health costs,
and therefore I don't eat candy.
And that choice
is the same today
versus next week versus
two weeks from now,
and so on and so forth.
So once I make a choice
for eating candy--
so here notice that the
person who will make the plans
to not eat candy in the future,
once the future arrives,
that person will
change their choice
and then actually
surprise themselves,
potentially by eating candy.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: There's just
behaviors in the world that
the exponential discounting
model cannot explain.
That is one of them.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: So there's--
yeah.
So I think there's
a question on what
other models can explain this.
I think the hyperbolic model
is, in fact, quite similar,
as it sort of showed
you in the curve here.
You sort of see the discount
functions are quite similar.
There's research using
the hyperbolic model.
In economics in the last sort
of-- in behavioral economics
in the last something
like 20 years,
the quasi-hyperbolic
model is the model
that everybody uses, partially
for tractability and simplicity
for no other good
reasons in many settings.
But in some sense, what we
care about-- in some sense,
I don't care actually that much
about which model among sort
of a class of model that are
quite similar can explain
things sort of--
if two models explain the
same thing in similar ways,
I don't care about
which one we should use.
In a sense, the simpler model
is sort of easier to use,
and that's why we sort of do it.
What I care about is
there are some predictions
from the exponential model
that are sort of just not--
that are just false.
And those we need to improve on.
That could be either
through a hyperbolic model
or quasi-hyperbolic model.
To keep things simple, I'm using
the quasi-hyperbolic model,
in part because it
nests very simply
in the exponential model.
And the reason why
a lot of economists
have used it is to say, OK,
here's an exponential model.
We know how to use that model.
Now we're going to
add one parameter
and things look very similar.
And beta equals 1 essentially
collapses that model back
to the exponential model.
And therefore,
people have used it.
And that's essentially
what we do.
OK.
So now the flip side of
those kinds of choices
are investment goods.
Investment goods are
essentially very similar.
These are goods that
have immediate costs
but delayed benefits.
An example would
be go to the gym.
Like, you can go to
the gym right now.
Some people find that
fun, but many people also
find it costly.
There's some effort cost
of, say, in this case, 2.
There's benefits,
health benefits, of 3.
Again, that's really sort
of like a stark example.
But I'm just trying to make sort
of a point to make this simple.
Now, again, if we have beta
equals 1/2 and delta equals 1,
if you think about should
you go to the gym today,
the answer is no.
And the reason is that you put
a lot of weight on the present.
You put sort of weight
of 1 on the present,
the cost of minus 1--
sorry.
You put a weight of 1
on the cost of minus 2.
So you have minus 2 costs.
The benefits are in the future.
You discount them by beta.
So you have 1/2 times 3,
which is smaller than 0.
Now, if you think
about, then, are
you planning to go to the gym
next week, the answer is yes.
Why is that?
Well, now you're essentially
discounting everything
that's in the future, including
the costs of going to the gym.
So you can think about, should
you go to the gym next week?
The answer will be yes.
The reason is because the
health benefits overall
are larger than the costs.
Now, again, what we're
going to see then
is people deviate from
their long-run plans.
Now they under-consume
investment goods
relative to long run plans.
So we saw previously that people
over consume leisure goods.
They do too much
fun stuff that has
bad consequences in the future.
And people tend to do too
little of tedious stuff
that will yield benefits
in the future relative
to their long run plans.
Again, you look at sort
of timing consistency
in a sense of, like, if I plan
to go to the gym next week,
I'm going to say yes.
Now unless things change,
once next week arrives,
I'm going to be at
the choice of, like,
should I go to the gym today?
I'm going to say no.
I would like to not do
that because now I'm
essentially discounting the
future but not the present.
Any questions on that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] one
more time why you discount
the efforts as in
the future and not--
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So think of these as different
periods-- so the effort--
so if you think about, should
you go until the costs are
today--
think about these are
different periods.
Period right now.
Health benefits are,
like, say, a week later.
OK.
In the choice about
doing it today,
the costs are right now--
that's the present period.
So if you go back to
the discount function,
you put a weight of 1 on
anything that's in the present.
And anything that's in the
future, a future period,
you put in a weight of 1/2.
AUDIENCE: OK, so we can see
every [INAUDIBLE] in the future
because [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So the effort right
now is in the present.
So for like-- so start with
a choice of, like, today.
The effort is in the present.
That's why I'm not sort
of discounting that
in the first choice for today.
But if I think about
doing it next week,
then next week is
also in the future.
I'm discounting everything
that's in the future,
whether it's a week
away or two weeks ago.
I don't care.
And therefore, everything
is discounted by 1/2.
OK.
So now one important distinction
now is demand for commitment,
or is there
commitment available?
So what we're going
to do is think
about like students who have
to do problem sets with very
simple beta delta preferences.
So consider a student with beta
equals 1/2, delta equals 1.
There's three periods.
And this is sort
of getting pretty
close to what you're going
to do in the problem set,
actually, yourself.
There are three periods.
You have to do the problem
set in exactly one of three
periods.
That's, of course, contrived
and a little stylized.
But that's just an
example for now.
So there's periods T equals
0, T equals 1, T equals 2.
The instantaneous utility
is of minus 1, three halves,
and five halves.
So the problem set becomes
more and more painful the later
we actually do it.
OK.
And there's only one day in
which you can actually do it.
So now the first thing
that I think about is
suppose there's
commitment available.
What does that mean?
Suppose a student
can essentially just
pick, when is she going
to do the problem set,
and actually stick to that.
Suppose they could
just sort of dictate
what she's going to do in the
future, what would she choose?
Well-- and then she actually
has to sort of stick with that.
So now we can sort think about,
from the perspective of period
zero, remember the person
is a hyperbolic discounter
with beta equals 1/2.
From the perspective of right
now, I'm going to say, well,
the discounted utility
today is minus 1.
There's no discounting happening
for today if I do it today.
For tomorrow, I'm going to
discount the future by 1/2.
So I'm going to get minus 3/4.
And in the period 2
in 2 days from now,
I'm going to do 1/2 minus--
times minus five halves,
which is five quarters.
So if I could sort of predict--
if I could sort of say what
I would like to do, I
would say, well, I'm
going to do it in
[INAUDIBLE] equals 1.
I'm going to do it tomorrow if I
could follow through with that.
Is that clear?
OK.
So that's if commitment
is available.
That is if I could
essentially just force
myself to do stuff
in the future and not
deviate from that at all.
Now if no commitment
is available,
how does that thinking change?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: T equals
1 [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, exactly.
Once T equals 1 arrives,
I might actually
prefer not to do
it in T equals 1
but rather say I'd rather
do it in T equals 2.
And this is exactly what
you're going to see here.
This is the exact same problem
that I showed you before.
Now, suppose the student
has no [INAUDIBLE]
so the commitment
technology is just to say,
what if the student can just
choose in every period, what
is she going to do, would she
actually do it in period one?
Well, if period one arrives,
if the problem set is not
done, if she does
it at period one,
from the perspective
of period one,
the discounted costs
are minus three halves.
That's just because that's
in the current period
from the perspective
of period one.
If she instead sort of were
to do it in period two,
she now discounts, again,
period two from the perspective
of period one by 1/2.
So 1/2 times minus
5/2 hops is 5/4.
Well, 5/4 is less bad than 3/2.
So she is going to say, I'm
going to do it in period two.
So that's to say that students'
preferences are dynamically
inconsistent.
Again, that's sort of
something that the exponential
discounting model would not
predict or cannot explain
and the quasi-hyperbolic model
is one way of simply creating
such timing consistency.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering how
we should think about the fact
that, for example,
you know that you're
going to experience [INAUDIBLE]
on the second period.
So should then your second
period activity function
be the one that matters?
Shouldn't you, as a
sophisticated [INAUDIBLE]
minus 3/2 that it's worse from
your perspective [INAUDIBLE]..
That utility function should
be the one that matters
and is used [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right so
you're sort of saying--
and sounds if I understood
right-- is to say--
and let's see
whether that's true.
You're saying, well, if no
commitment is available,
I should never let
it get to that point.
If I'm in period
zero, I should know
I'm not going to do it
actually in period one.
Therefore, I'd rather
do it right now
to avoid that all sort of like
procrastinated from period one
to period two.
And if I'm not in
period 0, I might
say I do it rather right now,
because otherwise I'm going
to just do it in period two.
And from the perspective
of period zero,
I'd rather do it right now,
compared to period two.
I would prefer to
do it in period one,
but that's not feasible because
my period one self will not
behave in the absence
of commitment.
AUDIENCE: I was more thinking
in a way that, why would
you want to commit your
previous one [INAUDIBLE]
that your [INAUDIBLE]?
Because you have a
different utility
function in that period.
[INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: It's just a--
I mean, something
that's an assumption
in the sense of from the
perspective of period zero,
you make certain choices.
You're going to say, I
could do it right now.
I could do it in period one.
Or I could do it in period two.
Now, you have
certain preferences.
And you're saying
maybe your preferences
should be different.
And that's obviously fine.
I sort of specified the
preferences for the student.
I said that beta is 1/2.
So she cares about
1/2 about anything
that happens in the
future in period one
and two compared to period zero.
And then sort of
just sort of like--
you just look at what
the utilities are and it
sort of turns out that from her
perspective, from period zero,
she prefers period one.
Now, you could sort of
specify the utility function
differently.
But for that specific
example, I guess
that's what sort of
the algebra tells us.
Yeah.
So now the key question
now is to say, OK,
now the preferences are
dynamically inconsistent.
So now what I said-- well,
what's really important now--
and in some sense, maybe
you were asking about that,
as well--
is, well, it's the
question on, like,
is the student aware of
this time of consistency?
So you could say, well, when
deciding in period zero,
you might sort of say, well,
I'd like to do it in period one.
If I believe that in period
one, I'm time consistent,
or if I believe that I'm
an exponential discounter
in the future, I will be
very virtuous in the future,
well then, I'm very happy
to wait until period one.
And then I'm going to follow
through with my plans.
If instead I know
that in period one
I'm going to be
present bias, well then
what's going to happen is then
I can't trust myself in period
one to actually do it.
I know I'm going to
procrastinate further
until period two.
So I'd rather do
it at period zero
to avoid sort of having to
deal with it in period two.
Let me sort of walk
you through that.
So I guess we need sort
of additional parameters
to start with which
is called beta hat.
Beta hat does essentially
the sophistication or naivete
parameter.
Beta hat is your
belief about what
you think your beta
will be in the future.
So beta is like what
the actual beta is.
That's the true value of beta in
the present and in the future.
And beta hat is
like what you think
your beta is in the
future, what you
believe your true or your
beta is going forward.
It's not what you believe--
you know your beta today.
You know that essentially
your present bias today.
Everybody understands that well.
That's an assumption, as well.
But people do not
know or may not
know what their beta
is in the future.
And that's what the parameter
of beta hat measures.
You're going to
have three cases.
I'm going to talk
about two cases today.
There's going to be a third
case starting on Tuesday.
And so the two cases that we
are discussing is full naivete.
That's to say my
beta hat equals 1.
That's to say I
think-- essentially,
I know I'm present biased today.
But I think I'm an exponential
discounter in the future.
OK, so that's to say
I know I have self
control problems right now.
But next week surely
will be different.
Like this is like in the
beginning of the semester,
you know you kind of like
screwed up in the past.
But this semester will
be very different.
You'll be virtuous and so on.
That happens kind
of every semester.
So that's beta hat equals 1.
So the person does not realize
that she will change her mind.
She thinks that she's going to
follow through with her plan.
Her plan is to do
it in T equals 1.
She thinks she's going
to follow through.
There will be surprises
about present bias
because you think you're
going to do it in period one.
Period one arrives, and
surprise, she's present biased.
She misestimated what
she's going to do
and then ends up
sort of not doing it
and has to do it
then in period two.
There's a sort of
like false optimism,
if you want, about future
plans and sort of the attitude
of this time is different.
From tomorrow onwards, things
will be very different.
We'll be all virtuous
in the future.
And then the second
part is sort of like--
call it like perfect
sophistication.
That's bets hat equals beta.
That is essentially
rational expectation
in a sense-- this is a person
who perfectly understands
their preferences.
I know I have seen
this movie before.
I know tomorrow I'm
going to procrastinate,
or I'm going to
be present biased.
I perfectly understand
what I'm going to do.
And therefore I take
into account that when
making choices right now.
And so she understands perfectly
that she will change her mind.
So she understands that she has
plans to do it in period one.
But she understands
that the period one
self has different preferences.
The period one self prefers
to do it in period two
rather than in period one.
So she's kind of like, in
some sense, sort of correctly
pessimistic about
her future self.
And sort of then in the case
of these kinds of investment
goods, that's a good
thing, because she doesn't
sort of leave stuff out.
She doesn't delay things
a lot for the future.
She doesn't let things
get bad because she knows
if she procrastinates
further, she'd
rather do it right
now, anticipating
that the future self
will not follow through.
And here in the perfect
sophistication case,
there will be no surprises.
The person always follows
through with their plans.
The third case I'm going
to talk about next week
is when beta hat equals--
is between beta and
one, which is we
call a partial sophistication
or partial naivety.
So it's a little more
complicated, but in fact,
quite similar.
I think there was a question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But the future self
actually can [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Sorry, say that again?
AUDIENCE: So the
person does not realize
that she will change
her mind over the course
of the semester, but she
[INAUDIBLE] her plans.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
So you would not
sort of-- so you wouldn't
really carry-- so if you change
your mind in the
future, you would not
carry through with your plans.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: So either
she will change her mind
in the future or not.
So if she doesn't change
her mind in the future,
there's no problem, because then
there is nothing to be aware.
That's kind of like the case
of the exponential discounter.
So if beta hat-- sorry, if beta
is actually one to start with,
which is kind of like
exponential discounting,
then there's no problem
because in the future
she will just want the
same as in the present.
So then sort of by construction
or by sort of assumption,
then beta hat equals
beta equals 1.
And now if she changes
her mind in the future
about her preferences--
essentially
if her beta is smaller than
1, then the question arises,
what's the beta hat?
Is it like one?
That's the perfect
sophistication case.
Or is it beta, which is--
beta hat equals beta.
That's the perfect
sophistication case.
Or if beta hat equals 1,
that's the full naivete case.
And then there's sort
of cases in between,
where she sort of-- she does
understand that the beta is
smaller than 1 in the future,
but doesn't fully understand
that and underestimates--
overestimates her beta, but
at least only to some extent.
Any other questions?
OK.
So now when we sort
of look at now,
what does a naive
student actually do?
So what does the naive
student do at T equals zero?
Well, from above,
we sort of know
that the self zero prefers to do
the problem set at T equals 1.
So since she's naive,
she thinks she's
going to follow through
with those plans.
So she believes that she will
actually do it at T equals 1.
So she doesn't do
it at T equals 0.
Now, of course, what
does she actually
do at period T equals 1?
We already said that.
She does actually not
want to do the period in T
equals 1, the p set
at period T equals 1.
So then hence the person sort of
surprises herself and actually
ends up doing it in period two.
Right.
And so what's sort of
the summary of that?
And this is a more
general phenomenon.
If you read the paper
for class today,
that's sort of much more
general in that paper
and you could do that in a
much more complicated way.
So essentially, there is
the belief in period zero--
she thinks, well, I can
not do it right now.
I can delay it.
The cost of delaying it
will not be that large
because I'm going to
just do it in period one.
But it turns out
the cost of delaying
is actually much larger,
because in period one,
she doesn't do it.
She'll do it in period two.
Now, if you had more
and more periods,
you could sort of have a whole
cascade of doing it every day--
every day you say you're
going to do it tomorrow,
but you're never
actually going to do it.
And so that can lead to
actually very large costs
of procrastination, because you
can essentially delay things
infinitely by
every time thinking
you're going to do
it in the future.
And so that kind of behavior
might persist for a long time.
And it's sort of an
example, as we call it,
like naive procrastination.
Every day you think--
or every week you
think you're going to do it
tomorrow or next week and so
on.
But you're never going
to actually do it.
And then that can lead to
really large welfare costs,
because there's stuff that's
actually not that hard to do.
But you just don't
do it every day
and it gets more and
more costly over time.
And you never end up doing it.
And it's way worse to do
it in 50 periods from now.
You could have just
done it early on
if you had understood
that you were not
going to do it any time soon.
Any questions on that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] what's
the interplay between learning
and sophistication [INAUDIBLE]?
What type of people [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
So one big question is,
how is this even possible
that we have here?
Here's a person who
keeps surprising herself
every period.
I mean, like, OK, actually, I
thought I was going to do it.
But surprise, I'm actually
not going to do it.
But I'll tomorrow I'll do it.
In a way, that's sort of
surprising, in the sense of,
like, there are these
behaviors-- like, for example,
when people think
about-- when do people
go to bed, for example?
And people think
people systematically
under invest in sleep.
And in some sense,
it's an odd sort
of behavior in the sense of,
you go to bed every night.
You kind of know that you're
going to be tired tomorrow.
Yet, every day you sort
of have this belief
that tomorrow
you'll be just fine.
And from tomorrow,
things will not change.
So there are some behaviors
that people tend to not learn.
And we don't quite
understand why that is.
In general, sort of like
learning about beta hat
is sort of--
kind of like at the frontier
of research right now.
People have started
estimating beta hat.
They have found people
tend to be fairly
naive in various situations.
But then the question
is, how is it possible
that people are so naive
in situations where, like--
we're going to the gym.
Every week you're going to have
the choice of going to the gym.
You should have
learned by now what
your type is, in some
sense, what your beta is.
And you should have
sort of then updated
your beliefs accordingly and
sort of changed your decisions.
But somehow people
have not done that.
And people tend to be
naive in situations
where really they have
lots of situations or lots
of occasions to learn.
Similarly, if you think
about problem sets
that you're doing,
in some ways you
know at the beginning of
the semester kind of what's
going to happen, in some ways.
We should now.
Yet, people tend to
be overoptimistic
in various cases.
I was an undergrad
advisor for a while.
And I was sort of advising
students on course choices.
Every semester it
was the same thing.
I would say, like, four
classes are grades, and so on.
Students would take,
like, six or seven.
And then I would say, well, you
know, that tends to not end up
very well.
Students are like, no, no, no.
This semester is different.
I'm going to work really hard.
It's going to be all great.
And then a month
later, we would meet.
And then we would go
down to five classes.
And I'd be like, well, maybe
four classes are also fine.
They're like, no, no, no, no.
Five classes are great.
And then at the end, we
end up at four or three.
So in a way, there are
a bunch of behaviors
that repeat over time.
And in some sense,
you would still
think, why are
people not learning?
One explanation why people
don't learn is in some sense,
they don't want to learn.
In the sense of like,
I like to be a person.
I like to think of
myself as a person who
is virtuous, who is hardworking,
who is going to be really doing
great at classes and so on.
So I want to be that person.
I feel better about
myself by wanting that.
And therefore, I might not
learn as much as I could,
even though that's
costly for me to do.
And we're going to talk
a little about this
in terms of overconfidence and
so on, where essentially people
have motivated
beliefs and people
want to be the person
with beta equals 1.
But in fact, they might not be.
OK.
So now what does the
sophisticated student do?
We already discussed that.
Essentially, the
person already knows.
The person has
rational expectations.
So the person knows that if she
doesn't do it in period zero,
she's not going to
do it in period one,
because the period one self
will change their minds
and not follow through
with her plans.
So she's going to
do it in period two.
Now anticipating
that for a choice
is essentially, effectively,
between doing it
right now versus in period two.
That's the effective
choice that she has.
And we can now just
make the choice.
Does she prefer doing it
period zero versus period two?
Well, she prefers doing
it in period zero,
because period two is
too costly for her,
even if that's in the future.
And therefore, she does
the problem set at period T
equals zero.
OK.
Any questions?
So what's the summary of that?
Well, the sophisticated student,
for a case of investment goods,
the person knows that if she
delays, she'll delay even more.
So once you start
procrastinating,
you know this is
going to unravel.
I'm never going
to actually do it.
And anticipating that,
she's going to say,
well, I'd rather
do it right now,
because I know this
is going to unravel
or this is going to
derail in the future.
I'd rather not have to do
it very late, late at night,
and so on and so forth.
So let me do it right now.
So that student in
that specific case
does better than
the naive student.
And for the case of
investment goods,
sophisticated
procrastination does not
cause large welfare costs.
It's not possible for a
perfectly sophisticated person
to procrastinate things for
a long time and sort of lead
to a very inefficient or
costly outcomes, the reason
being if you know that's going
to be costly in the future,
if it's really that bad, you
would rather do it right now.
And so therefore,
they cannot be--
there can be some
costs of delaying.
You might do it tomorrow-- you
might do it a little bit later
than optimally.
But it cannot be that you
procrastinated for a long time
and never do it and therefore
get like really large costs
of that.
OK.
So one question that also
came up in the online forum
that you also saw
in the readings
that we're going to also talk a
little bit about in the problem
set is, well, is
sophistication always good?
And it's very intuitive to
think that sophistication always
helps.
After all, knowing
things better,
having correct beliefs
about yourself,
that seems to be
the correct thing.
So intuitively, it feels
like that should only help,
should only make things better.
If I understood
my biases better,
I should be doing better.
Now, it turns out that's
true for investment goods.
So for investment
goods, these are
the goods where you have to
do something in the present,
but the costs-- sorry, the
benefits are in the future.
For that,
sophistication is always
better, or weakly
better, the reason
being that, again, you
can sort of understand
your future misbehavior.
And by that understanding
of future misbehavior,
you can sort of avoid bad
things happening in the future
by doing it right
now and earlier.
So in that case, sophistication
is always better.
Now, it turns out
for leisure goods,
that's actually not the case.
So leisure goods,
again, are goods
where you can enjoy
something in the present
and there may be some costs
delayed in the future.
And so let's look at-- and this
is very close to now the paper
that you read.
Suppose there's
a student who has
beta equals 1/2 and delta
equals 1, as before.
Suppose the student can go
to only one movie in exactly
one of the four periods.
There's only one movie
ticket that she could
use in period 0, 1, 2, and 3.
By the way, Matthew Rabin
is a huge Johnny Depp fan,
in case you haven't noticed.
So he uses Johnny Depp
in various of his papers,
and so on.
He also had a huge Johnny
Depp poster in his office.
So the instantaneous
utilities are
such that they're 1, 3/4,
9/4, and 27/8, so they're
sort of increasing over time.
So if you-- so
there's essentially
one day where it's like the
most fun to watch the movie,
perhaps because you can
go with your friends
or whatever-- like, it's
a better day to do it.
Maybe you're a bit better
rested or whatever it is.
But sort of delaying
would be good.
Now, the problem, of course, is
that the person is impatient.
The person might not want to
wait because the person is
present biased.
He might want to
watch it earlier.
The question now is,
when does she actually
go watch that movie?
So now there's a way in which
you can sort of write this down
in a very simple form, which
is a table of discounted
utilities.
That's a simple tool for
solving these kinds of problems.
This is supposed to
come sequentially,
but it isn't today,
it's on something that's
already filled out for you.
So that's easier for you.
So what I have filled
out for you here
is the instantaneous utility.
So the first row
here is essentially
to say, these are sort of
the assumptions that we have.
You have the
instantaneous utilities--
U0, U1, UT, U3, and so on.
So this is essentially
what you see
on the first row of this table.
Second then I filled out for
you sort of the utilities
from the perspective of period
zero, period one, and period
two.
So from the
perspective of T equals
0, the first period T equals
0 equals just the same.
That's just 1, because she
puts weight one on that.
But then everything
in the future
is discounted by 1/2,
because the beta is 1/2.
Yes?
And then from the
perspective of T
equals 1, of course T equals
0 is sort of irrelevant
because that was in the past.
By definition, we
only care about stuff
that happens in the
future, because we
can't change the past.
Notice that's also
an assumption,
but it's a common assumption
made in economics.
So there 3/2 now
is in the present.
So that gets weight 1.
And everything that's in
the future gets weight 1/2.
So you have 9/8 and 27/16.
And now for period 2 again--
period now 0 and
1 are in the past.
Now she cares about
the present [INAUDIBLE]
T equals 2 with the weight of 1.
That's 9/4.
And now T equals 3
is in the future.
That's discounted by 1/2.
OK.
And now what I also
have done, I've
written down the ranking
of these different periods
from the perspective of--
from the sort of just looking
at the instantaneous utilities,
three's better
than two is better
than one is better than zero.
From the perspective of T equals
0, you prefer three over two
over zero over one.
From T equals 1, you prefer
three over one over two.
And from the perspective
of T equals 2,
you prefer two over three.
Does this all make sense
what I've written down here?
I'll let you look at
this for a second.
OK.
So what does the naive person
do with beta hat equals 1?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Oh, wait, hold on.
FRANK SCHILBACH: We can
do this step by step.
AUDIENCE: OK, so
[INAUDIBLE] zero.
And then from the
perspective of T equals 0,
you would most prefer to
do something at time three.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I guess
that means that you
don't do it in period one and
then move on to T equals 1.
And then again you want
to do it in period three
so you don't do it
in period one here.
And then you end
up at T equals 2.
And then you'd rather do it in
period two than period three,
so you do it in period two.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
Correct.
So let me do that
in slow motion.
So in period T, she
makes some plans.
You wrote down what is her
preferred plan in period
T equals zero.
We have our ranking
at the very right
in the right-- in the
last column on the right.
She prefers to do
it in period three.
She thinks that she's going to
follow through with her plans.
So she's not going
to do it in period 0
because she thinks she
prefers period three.
So let's just wait.
So she doesn't go in
in periods T equals 0.
And period T equals
1 is the same thing.
And now she essentially
says, well, she
prefers three over one over two.
It's better to do
it in period three
so let's just wait
until period three.
Now, of course,
period two comes.
Once period two
comes, it turns out
we cooked up the number such
as like prefers a period
two over period three.
So she surprises herself by
actually watching the movie
in period two.
OK.
Any questions?
So now instead, what does
a sophisticated student do?
So this was the perfectly naive
student doing it and watching
the movie in period two.
No, if you're sophisticated,
what do you do?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: She starts
thinking that if she waits,
[INAUDIBLE] equals 2,
she's going to at two--
wait.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Correct.
AUDIENCE: So then she
knows that at T equals 1,
she's not going wait until two.
She's going to--
FRANK SCHILBACH: Any help?
Yes, OK.
AUDIENCE: So first student,
at T equals 2, she would go.
So if she were at T equals 1,
she knows that if she waits,
then she would go at
two instead of three.
But she likes one.
So her choice is not
between one and three,
but between one and two.
So if she were at time period
one, then she would go--
choose to go at one.
And then if she's
at time T equals 0,
her choice is going to be
between zero and one, not zero
and three.
So that if she were
at time period zero,
she would just end up
going at time period zero.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Correct.
So let me also say that
a little slower again.
So if we look at
perfectly naive people,
they're going to start from
the beginning and go forwards.
We have a naive person who
has plans going forward.
And then we just look at
how does this plan evolve?
So you start at how
does this person person
decide at period T
equals zero, thinking
she's going to follow through?
Then we go to
period one thinking
she's going to follow through.
Then we go to
period two thinking
she's going to follow through.
And that's how we sort
of solve the problem.
Now, for the
sophisticated person,
you would do things differently.
We essentially do this
backwards deduction, essentially
to say let's start
at the very end.
The reason that we can
use backwards induction
is because people have
rational expectations.
The person knows exactly
what she's going to do,
which is she's going
to start from the end
and say, OK, how is
this going to play out?
What am I going
to do in the end?
And sort of anticipating
that perfectly, we're
going to then solve backwards.
OK, so as you just
said, in period two,
we know that she's going to
go, if she hasn't, because she
prefers two over three.
That's the last
row that we have.
She likes two better than three
once she comes to period two.
Now, in period T
equals 1, she knows
that she's not going to
wait until period three.
So period three is actually
not an option for her.
She knows that's not credible.
She's not going
to follow through.
So then it's just a choice
between one and two.
She prefers one over two.
So she's going to--
going in period one.
Now then, in period
one two equals 0,
now we know-- she
realized that she
won't wait until two or three.
Two or three are not
an option for her.
She would actually prefer
both two and three.
But that's not possible because
her future self will not
stick to her choice.
So then the choice really just
becomes between zero and one,
and she prefers zero over one.
Now, essentially, she
goes to that movie,
and gets a trilogy of one.
But actually, she would prefer
any of these other outcomes--
actually, any of
her other self would
prefer her to not do that.
But she actually
picks period one.
So that's an example.
And there's several
examples of that
where sophistication can hurt.
Now, why is sophistication
hurting here?
What's the key
part, and why is it
worse for the student
to be sophisticated?
In some sense, if
you think about it
from the perspective
of T equals 0,
she would prefer a three
over two over zero over one.
Or overall, if you look at
the instantaneous utilities,
period two is better.
So from the perspective
of T equals 0,
period two is better
than period zero.
Yet, he ends up
going in period zero.
So a sophisticated
person actually
would be better off
if she were naive.
If she could sort of commit
to something and say,
I would prefer to go in
period two, if she could say--
if I only could be
naive, that would sort of
help her to actually
do it in period two.
Of course, you can't
sort of choose that.
But here she's worse off
from being sophisticated.
But what's going on here?
Like, why is that happening?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So she almost
mistrusts her future self
and so preempts that by
taking the previous decision.
But then also
preempting that, she
would preempt her future self.
She would take the
previous decision again.
And so that makes it so
that she does the action
at the very start instead.
For us, the naive person
always blunders through
and manages to take the more--
the action with
the higher utility.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So in some ways, the problem is
set up in a way that, in a way,
realistic pessimism--
the sophisticated person
is, like, realistic
in their pessimism.
She knows, essentially,
that in the future
she's not going to behave.
So she would love to wait.
But what she needs
to do to wait,
she needs to have a sufficiently
high benefit of waiting.
Now, how high is the
benefit of waiting?
It depends on what your
future self is going to do.
If you only wait a little
bit, the person will say,
if I go-- if the choice
is between zero and one,
it's not worth waiting.
I might as well go right now.
So if I can wrongly sort of
have the illusion to myself
that I say, well,
I'm going to not
go in one, or in two, for that
matter, then in some sense
the benefits of waiting-- the
perceived benefits of waiting
are higher than
they actually are.
And in this case, it mitigates
the self-control problem
or the present bias.
The present bias person
wants to do it right now
and needs a sufficiently
high reward for waiting.
So if you can sort of perceive--
if you can sort of
deceive yourself
into thinking that the
rewards of waiting are high,
you're going to actually wait.
And that's good for
you in this case.
If, instead, you're realistic
about your future self,
you know that waiting is not
really helping you very much.
You know that essentially,
if you wait for one period,
you're going to go and go
in the next period, anyway.
So then the reward--
and that's in part because the
numbers are set up that way--
but that's now essentially
sort of telling you,
well, waiting is not
really doing very much,
because your future self
is also misbehaving.
It sort of makes it
impossible to actually wait
all the way until the very end.
And therefore, it sort of
makes the self-control problem,
the present bias,
worse, because now it's
like it's not worth-- why even
bother to wait a little bit,
because that's literally
not worth doing?
Really what you would need
is wait all the way through.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I think
this is related to what
I was trying to ask before.
If you're sophisticated, you
know you have [INAUDIBLE]..
If you are in
period zero, you'll
know that on the next
period, you're [INAUDIBLE]..
So why would you prefer to
experience [INAUDIBLE] one now
[INAUDIBLE] experience
[INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: No,
but I think it's--
in a way, there is
a preference over--
and something like that's,
again, an assumption
how people behave.
People care a lot
about the present.
And that's sort of
like, in some sense,
in a bunch of experiments
and so on, people really
want stuff right
now, even if they
know that they will prefer
stuff in two days from now
or three days from
now and so on.
You just-- you are
impatient right now.
And that's what the
utility function is like.
And so you put less weight on
stuff that's in the future.
Now, if you sort think about
your future preferences,
there's a question on-- that's
a philosophical question
in some ways-- how do
you think about the fact
that your future self
wants something different?
That is to say, for example,
if I want to exercise a lot
and I also like to sit on
the couch and watch TV a lot,
now my current self wants to
exercise a lot in the future.
My future self wants
to-- and I know that--
wants to sit on the couch.
Now the question
is which-- and when
you think about
welfare and so on,
which self should we respect?
And one assumption-- and
this is an assumption
that's built in here-- is
to say my current self has
certain plans for the future.
And those preferences
are the preferences
that I'm using to maximize.
I know that my future
self wants other things.
But in some sense, I'm assuming
I know that I know better.
This is the utility function
that counts is the current one,
not the future one.
And so then I respect
that one and I'm
trying to maximize
that sort of subject
to my future preferences
being different.
But in some sense,
you're exactly right.
If you think about,
like, should we
tax potato chips, for example--
talk about welfare and so on--
should we tax potato chips?
You could say, well,
on the one hand,
I might say I would like
to tax potato chips,
because I know in
the future I'm going
to eat too many potato chips.
That's good for me.
But there's a future self--
actually, myself-- who would
love to eat potato chips.
That self would
be really unhappy.
Now you get very tricky
questions of welfare
and a sense of
saying, like, well,
who are we to say
that the current self
is different or should get
priority over the future self?
The future self will
really be unhappy.
So there are different
views on this.
Some people, including Matthew
Rabin including David Laibson
and so on, would
sort of say, what
counts is the current
self, or a self
that chooses for the future.
That's sort of the
virtue of self and so on.
We should use that for
welfare evaluation.
That's an assumption.
There's other people who would
argue that no, like, there's
all sorts of self who
want different things.
So if you think about,
is it good to increase
taxes for potato chips?
Maybe, because some
selves are better off
and some selves are worse off.
And how do we ever aggregate
across those different selves?
So you get very
tricky questions.
But here for our purposes
what we're going to do
is we're going to say the
current self is essentially
disrespecting future
utility functions
and preferences in
the own maximization
and the maximization problem.
That is to say, I have a
utility function right now,
and sort of discounting
function that tells me
how I want to aggregate my
future utility over time.
That is what I want.
And then I have essentially like
a-- sort of like constraints
which are coming sort of in
the-- when I think about sort
of like when you write down a
utility maximization problem,
there's an objective function,
which is my maximization
problem.
That's the utility function
that I want right now.
And then there's constraints
in your maximization
problem, which
are in the future,
my preferences will change.
So some options
might not be feasible
because of these preference
reversals, and so on.
But that's not to say--
I'm respecting your future
preferences to the extent
that I need to have
feasible plans.
I'm not respecting
them in the sense of,
like, I know right now.
I know better what's
good for myself.
Did that answer your question?
OK.
Any other-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Sorry, what
exactly is the question?
AUDIENCE: So does that mean that
if you go see the movie in T
equals 2, do you evaluate
that as-- sorry, [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: So from the
perspective of period T equals
2, you evaluate it with 9/4.
From the perspective
of period T equals
1 or T equals 0, that
is in the future.
So you multiply
the 9/4 times 1/2,
which is the beta because
it's in the future.
AUDIENCE: So then when
you say the student does
better [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: I'm using
sort of from that perspective.
So in some sense, that's a bit
of a question philosophically,
what's better and worse, because
you have different perspective.
You can take from the
perspective of T equals 0--
for example, a
sophisticated person
would much prefer period
two over period zero, one
over zero.
So I just showed you that
the sophisticated person
goes in period zero.
But in fact, the person
would prefer a three and two.
So the outcome of
the naive person
would be better for the
sophisticated person
from the perspective
of T equals 0.
And so then there's
a bit of a question.
From the perspective
of t equals 2,
if you had gone already
in the previous period,
probably prefer if you
hadn't gone previously.
But that's a bit
silly, in some sense.
But you can essentially-- you
can write down for each self,
what would each self prefer?
And I think as it is in this
example, it's essentially,
the sophisticated essentially
does worse for all selves
compared to a-- weakly worse
compared to the naive person.
OK, but happy to talk after.
OK, so I think we
have all of that.
Sophistication can
make things worse.
So now overall let me--
so more generally,
the lessons are--
so the question is kind of
like whether future misbehavior
raises or lowers the cost
of current misbehavior.
So essentially, whether
future and current misbehavior
are compliments or substitutes--
so if future misbehavior raises
the costs of
current misbehavior,
then sophistication helps
in overcoming short run
impatience.
That tends to be true
for investment goods.
That was the example
that I showed you first.
If I know I'm going to
misbehave in the future,
I'm not going to like--
I'm going to procrastinate a
lot if I don't do it right now.
Then sophistication
is good because I
can sort of prevent that by
just doing stuff right now.
So those are the investment
goods with immediate cost.
There are some
exceptions to that.
But generally, that
tends to be true.
Now, if instead
future misbehavior
lowers the costs of
current misbehavior,
because essentially the
benefits of waiting in this case
that I showed you for the
movie are just lower now,
so the costs of misbehaving now
have become lower, then I say,
well, I might as
well do it right now.
I might as well eat the
cake right now, or whatever.
There's no point in waiting.
So then sophistication hurts
in overcoming short run
impatience.
And that tends to be the
case for leisure goods.
So avoid immediate rewards.
Now-- yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: It has to--
it's a little tricky.
It's kind of complicated.
In some sense, it has to
do with specific cases.
But the key question
is essentially is like,
in the future, does
sophistication or misbehavior
raise or lower the costs
of future misbehavior?
Does it raise or lower the
costs of current misbehavior?
And then depending on whether
that's the case, sophistication
or naivete go in
different directions.
So essentially there's
a true answer to that.
And then essentially if
you're naive to this,
it sort of flips the direction,
depending on the numbers.
But it's more
complicated to that.
It sort of-- these are sort
of fairly general statements.
So it's a little complicated.
But you'll see some examples
again in problem sets
and so on.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does anybody
model [INAUDIBLE]??
FRANK SCHILBACH: Not so much.
So usually people tend to-- so
that's an interesting question.
So usually people think beta
hat or any preference parameters
are often independent of the
costs and choices that you see.
So the idea often
is you are born
with a beta and a
beta hat and a delta
and so on that fell
somehow from the sky.
There's some research on how
environmental factors and so
on affect preferences.
For example, we'll
show you some research
on how contact with
different types of people
affect your social preferences.
For example, if you are
exposed to many poor people
as a rich person
in your life, you
might become a nicer person
and things like that.
I'll show you some
research about that.
So there's some research on
how exposure to environments
affects people's preferences.
In the case of time
preferences, usually people
just think by
assumption, somehow you
came with a certain
discount factor,
and that's how it is,
or beta delta and so on.
That applies to all
sorts of settings.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But if it's less
costly, you should be
able to be more sophisticated.
So I mean--
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
That's an interesting question.
So that's not what people
have done and thought about.
In a way, there's
a bit of a question
whether your cost
and benefit structure
can explain your behavior
for a given beta hat.
But it might also be that for
some case-- in some situations,
you might say you want to be--
for example, what I
was saying earlier,
it's like, why are
people not learning?
For some behaviors,
maybe you actually
don't care if your beta
is 0.7 or whatever.
It's like, fine.
But some people really care
about being a good and virtuous
person.
And therefore these might
be important choices in life
that you would say,
I'm a serious person.
I do this well.
My beta hat--
you'd like to think
of yourself as your
beta being high.
That's not what people
have done very much.
So there's a little
bit of research
of good, specific discounting,
like your discounting
for certain goods might be
different than for others,
depending on what kinds
of goods they are.
So some goods are temptation
goods and others are not.
Even that is not really in
the mainstream of economics
very much, let alone sort of
saying your beta hat varies
by circumstance.
I think that's a very nice idea.
I don't know any research
that has done that so far.
OK.
So now one question
you might ask--
well, is it beneficial
to be sophisticated?
Couldn't we just all be naive
and everybody's better off?
So in theory-- at
least in principle--
it's sort of unclear whether
sophistication is good.
As I told you--
I showed you just an example--
in some cases it's good
and other cases it's bad.
If you think overall
many important decisions
or choices in life
tend to be decisions
that involve one term--
one time efforts that
yield future benefits,
these are investment goods.
So in many cases in life, you
have sort of investment goods--
like finishing papers,
presentations, reports,
finding good investment
options for retirement,
quitting bad habits, quitting
smoking, finding a job,
and so on and so forth.
So lots of choices
are essentially
immediate effort, or at
one time or several times
putting in effort right now
where you get future benefits.
So a lot of important
things in life
tend to be investment goods.
And in that case, I
guess sophistication
tends to be good.
So essentially it helps you.
Now, in addition,
sophisticates take advantage
of commitment devices.
So I offer you a
commitment device
that I was discussing earlier.
The sophisticated
person will say, great.
The commitment
device might help me.
Great.
I'm going to demand it and might
be better off because of that.
I'm going to show you next week
commitment devices don't always
work.
Maybe sometimes they could
actually make things worse.
But in principle, at least, you
think commitment devices could
improve things, and sort of in
that sense, being sophisticated
is good.
So I think overall,
if I had to choose
if I'm sophisticated or
naive, I would probably
choose to be sophisticated,
at least in this case.
Whether that's actually
true, I'm not so sure.
There's one somewhat
more subtle thing here
is to say, like, is it sort
of-- is the issue here really
impatience or time
inconsistency-- in a sense of,
is it just about people not
caring sufficiently much
for the future?
Or is it about how important
is time inconsistency?
And as I said, some of the
behavior that I'm going to
show--
that I showed you is,
impatience is not really
the key issue here.
It's not about people
not necessarily caring
about the future, but rather,
people switching their choices
and choosing dominated
options in the sense
of overall dominated.
If you sort of commit,
there are some options
that you prefer that you end
up not choosing because you
change your choices over time.
Impatience cannot create
this type of behavior.
What I showed you, where the
sophisticated person says,
I would like these options
but I'm not choosing them
because I know my future
self will change their minds,
that is not possible.
You cannot generate this
behavior coming from just
impatience.
A delta being 0.5 or
whatever would not
generate you this behavior.
What you need is
time inconsistency.
You need, essentially,
preference reversals over time.
OK, so then in
some ways I think--
perhaps more most practical
for your purposes, in part,
for the problem set--
how do we solve sort
of problems with
quasi-hyperbolic discounting?
So as I told you before,
for the naive person,
we can start from the beginning.
And why do we start from the
beginning as a naive person?
Why does this work?
So I sort of showed you
already how to solve it.
Now I'm sort of generalizing
that, in some sense.
Why is that a
useful thing to do?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
So the naive person thinks,
I'm going to make plans now
for the future.
And by assumption,
the naive person
thinks they're going to
follow through on those plans.
So what you can
essentially do is
you can start with
some plans, see
what the person is
choosing thinking they're
going to follow through.
You don't have to
worry about what's
going to happen in the
future, because you
can explain perfectly what the
person is doing in the present
by making plans for--
sorry, by making your choice
for the future periods.
You don't have to
actually worry about
whether the person is
going to follow through,
because the person doesn't
even think about that.
So you say, I make a
plan for the future,
assuming I'm going to
stick through with that,
or stick to this.
And then you can just
sort of roll forwards
and say, OK, I start
with period T equals 0,
make the plan for that, think
I'm going to follow through.
Surprise, maybe
period one I'm going
to do something different.
But then I'm going to have the
same assumption, and so on.
I can just go from T
equals 0 going forward
under the assumption that I'm
going to stick to those plans.
For the sophisticated
person, that
doesn't work, because a
sophisticated person knows
that if I make some
plans for the future,
those might not be feasible
because the future self will
misbehave and
change their plans.
I know essentially that
some plans are not feasible.
So what I need to do
is essentially just
start from the end and see,
OK, if certain options are
available, what I'm
going to do, and then
walk backwards to solve it.
And that's essentially
rational expectations
where essentially you perfectly
understand your future behavior
and sort of take into
account your future choices.
You're going to make them
current choices at the end.
What about the
exponential person?
How does that person
solve the problem?
AUDIENCE: I just had a question
about what you just said.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So to summarize a
sophisticated person, where
they're going from the
end to the beginning,
as they move backwards, are
you just removing choices
that you know you won't ever--
FRANK SCHILBACH: Correct.
Exactly.
So what we did in
the movie choice,
if you go through this
example in more detail,
you'll notice that
essentially, if I know that,
for example, suppose I
want to go in period three
but I know I'm going
to go in period two
if it comes down
to that, then I'm
going to remove period three for
my choice set or for my options
when optimizing in period
one or period zero,
anticipating what I'm
going to do in the future.
So what about the
exponential discounter?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
So there's two options, in fact,
for the exponential discounter.
It actually doesn't matter
because you follow through
with your plans anyway.
So you could start
from the beginning
and just walk forward.
In fact, what you can do is
you can start in period zero
make a plan for everything
and just follow through.
You don't even have
to go to period
1, 2, and 3 because
you know you're
going to stick to that plan.
So you can essentially
just do that.
You could actually also
do backward transactions.
And I'm pretty sure you
get the exact same answer.
It doesn't matter.
The much easier thing
to do, of course,
is to solve the
problem in period 0
and then just assuming you're
going to follow through.
So sorry, this should
say readings for Tuesday.
The class is on
Tuesday, not on Monday.
Please read the paper by
Ariely and Wortenbroch.
Read the entire article.
We're going to discuss
applications from smoking
to drinking, setting
deadlines, and so on,
and apply these models
in real-world settings.
Thank you very much.